das schließt erst im und dass ich mit
der bbc awo voneinander strömt
[Musik]
bislang ist
liebe fragt nicht nach dem pass bibel
kann grenzenlos sein
liebe nimmt uns an der hand und schon
sind wir hin und weg das sind weiter
liebesgeschichten aus aller welt
[Musik]
ich bin unterwegs noch schwede zu der
anja und anja kürze der viele die sich
schweizerinnen und schweizer was ich
über glauben dass grenzen muss verliert
obwohl sie selber um ihre mission tätig
liebe monat vor ein paar jahren erzählte
mir ein freund er hätte in späten meinen
traummann kennengelernt
ich lachte ihn aus und dachte das sei
ein scherz
nun sind acht jahre vergangen und ich
lebe als bäuerin in schweden vielleicht
gefällt ja meine geschichte dann erzähle
ich dir gerne mehr liebe grüße und ein
schritt vielleicht erinnere studio nicht
mehr sicher vor über 20 jahren einmal
miteinander kommt die frauen feld
gefahren und ich erinnere mich natürlich
aber gesehen hat
genau darum flügel jetzt auftreten
die 1 damit weckt er beats und andere
wie tanja warum reagieren landesgrenze
ich meistens als einzige hindernis
überwinden
keiner verliert steht und plötzlich
schloss die enns krems land an fremden
ort oder sind sie schon mal stars dort
xxi
er ist der star nicht
gar kein richtiges dorf 10
dorina also wo und anja mit ihrem sohn
max und ihre marke husqvarna dritte tüte
das trifft sich gut will wie schwedisch
beschränkt sich auf wenige begriffe mödl
katalog
[Musik]
hallo ich sagen ja zwar lagen schon
übrigens nur studierende jetzt gut
gefunden hätte das summiert seine tablet
sind kam die frau fällt denkt das
turnier der ersten glocke und in
schweden dabei das möglich 2
[Musik]
der schwedische trauma schön wenn sie
das rumgesprochen hat das überhaupt
dass der kollege von anja diese so
abreise happy ihre dass gewisse
nervosität da wirklich komische brillen
auf das anja schnell gemerkt da geht die
multi park mit 150 aber dass sie bald
dir wird sie wo die ehre
das hat sie dort sich und ganz hin und
weg in die türkei
und das auf und und und das toll was
natürlich den energie und peter hamacher
hängen wie im song meine karriere mini
familie aus zurücklag und da hätte das
gleiche gemacht
[Musik]
ja
wo doris hofer von 14 jahre vom musiker
bb auf istanbul zogen ist sie das zwei
hektar liebe gemacht aber nur dreck
torhüterin faden riss
sie hat sich in chats manipuliert und
ich wegen ihm die türkei zog seine 12
kind der sohn noah und tochter zu sind
natürlich immer noch ihres große glück
aber ihre ehe ist nach acht jahren bush
kommt übrigens aus der hälfte vor allem
die nationalen tv misch mit handychips
drucker ist für doris hoffe die frau
q.met wähler das training die dänische
vom ford dreifach sind und zweitens hat
sie es als fitness bloggerin zu
nationaler bekanntheit gebracht
[Musik]
das land kann er die möglichkeit fühle
mich sehr wohl und habe sofort also nach
der schäden könne mit seinem logo
auffangen und ich jetzt drei akteure
investiert
doris hat gemacht was die meisten mit
ihrer situation ortet aber nicht
wirklich alle schafe hat jedoch das
nicht gemacht hat
ich glaube wenn das macht der ist
wirklich frei nach dass eine depression
dank hey das ist wichtig das ist ein
teil von ihm lag
wir glauben haben wenn du irgendwie
positiv dank
das ist traurig
doris hoffe ich in istanbul bleibe
heimat vor ihrem ex mann und für
jaschinski würde ich bin schon zum
schuss und schaum flugplatz gestanden
und hat denn eigentlich wartet so
hoffnungsvoll und dann weiß noch ganz
genau dass ich so in ganz also nicht im
traum auf mich zu und hexe ist annika
sieg und aber sie ist der netze ob sie
ist ein addon liga und hat in einem
sektor sich sicher den grausamen selbst
besaß und so ist denn auch sie und
bedankt sich
[Musik]
sowie ihrem ersten stars dort hat anja
zimmermann gemerkt dass iris lemmer der
schwedische wie die schuldenfalle
eigenes eigene weiden und wälder zum
geräte und wo dir genauso gerne wie sie
da sich im februar 2009 250 und über 200
jungtier versorger tanja und auf ihrem
hof und fast jeden tag und das gelb
erneut zu prüfen und zwar nicht von
irgendwo sondern aus der schweiz
so höre dass brown wieder so sozial
eingestellt das gefällt uns auch sehr
gut sie auch noch lustig also das ist
eine schweizer frau und du bringst die
schweizer kühe eigentlich nach schweden
oder also brown swiss sind ja wirklich
unsere schweizer kühe zuerst in die
schweizer frau oder in die schweiz
krasse verliebt also das kann eigentlich
ziemlich gleichzeitig das erste beim
swiss-cup waschen auf der welt als die
anja kam aber klar die ufer
das war im vorfeld ziemlich hier und
anja ihre schulden schmid turnier gilt
die genetik und das ist großes interesse
von mir das kann die anja reich gut aber
wie sah man kann sie zum beispiel nicht
das macht nur ich mein essen kochen für
uns alle
die natur da einkaufen gehen und so die
guckt machen max dass der immer in die
schule kommt das ist so oder anja ihrem
aufgabenbereich aber die pferde macht
die anja im großen ganzen ganz allein
[Musik]
ballack ist das schön weil ich ja so
jetzt daheim eigentlich so ein
absperrgitter gemacht bei meinen jüngern
die füße dass teresa sitzen die hörer
was einst der eis ließen und dann ist
das so verschießen unterlaufen
[Musik]
sogar eindruck von mir ja doch die frau
nicht gekannt war das ein party und
schickst du was bist du für mensch und
vieh ich den dax sind dann bist du ich
mir auf göteborg kreis
ungefähr so die sympathie die war schon
war mit dem schreibstil ja und
telefonieren die heizung telefoniert
haben wir und das ist ein jahr ist
bestätigt worden also gut mir ist ja
jetzt nicht darum mit dem ziel zum
flughafen gefahren was wir nachher
zusammen in der familie gründen aber
dass ich das nachher so toll entwickelt
ich habe gespürt dass geschäft lief
erlebt oder so ich bin dann verliebt sie
und meint da der trapper bevor man sie
und er hat mir vorstelle küsse und und
dann habe ich gemerkt ich muss sagen und
dann heimlich befasst verliert zum und
sich so verlobt und zum heiraten und so
und einer text ohne dass ich ganz
traurig das heißt ich kann deine theater
und ich kann den kindern etat und wieso
und hat würde ich du na dann kann ich
gesagt natürlich
[Musik]
wenn immer möglich verbringen russia
unter bernard im hasli ein teil von sumo
in lachs im wallis für die burnout ist
es stück heimat sind große in trend in
lachs bleibt er selber ist mit 16 vom
wallis weg zu sehr stieß internats der
luft symptom erste hälfte vom jahr in
der heimat von ihren frauen indien
das wirklich frische luft die vage
aussicht dass zur zeit dass die walde
und schön
die hitze
und hier ist einfach ein paradies aber
aus paradies bucht auto zur neuen
anstrich und ganz so paradiesisch ist es
möglich
vodafone ziemlich genau 50 jahren in der
schweiz schwieriger weil frisch carlotta
und denn nun sind alle lüfter flughafen
sie und die ganze familie vom großvater
bis zum cousin cousine brüder schwestern
alle sind auf der flughafen koh an ihrer
seite sind wir auf zürich geflogen
kurz vor mir nach der flughafen sie hier
auf die es mit dem zug ist auf dem
bahnhof sie mit gebäck alles geschleppt
zu fuß von schwiegereltern und ich
wahnsinnig kalt und ich erinnere morgen
der erste morgen nicht stand
so war auch unser kopf obwohl es ist so
kalt sie nicht einmal ein hai ca die hat
denkt jeder gott nur wenig landes und da
ich mich erinnere ich sofort voller
geschwiegen adressen sehr warmherzig sie
und deshalb käufer
[Musik]
schwedens neues stück älter und gleicht
anders sehen wir mal nicht lang
gefackelt
[Musik]
die warm also serie gedenke bist du denn
zum beweggründe oder erstmals 750
flughafen und jetzt gesagt das ist
wichtig auch lieferung durch einsteiger
nicht um den konsum
ob ich von ihnen als würdige mit einem
verschleppt worden alles gut
aber jetzt hat sie sich gut damit auch
von heute freut sich im moment kommen
kann
da habe ich das nie zustande berufung
kam und das heimatland
das war ja es stimmt dass ich da auf den
großen
[Musik]
der berner dem hause hat lang als coach
wunder in francis india berichtet neu
delhi hat rau im diplomatischen dienst
geschaffen
oft wachsen aber eher im bescheidenen
sogar sehr ärmlichen verhältnisse große
hoch große tisch oder war nicht meins 12
14 15 liter turbo excel sind und wie
hoch ist eine stufe einer hexe war soll
ein hakenkreuz und und da sind die
einzige zimmermann hat die 100 zimmer
sind sind kalt ich sehe also ich weiß
wenn wir da wenn der mann ist rosi und
mir sehr und technisch nie für oder
entlehnt tiere dass ich sie sind die
sind stichhaltig sie möchten natürlich
ist die krise
bush anika kalovics gewärmt und ein
fenster wenn der berner im haus st vitus
dorf sein vorfahre spaziert fühlt er
sich motive für die heimische ich habe
trotzdem fast in fremde
die meisten wissen gar knapp wo das ist
schade hat aber wo das im hasli swiss
life ceo duncan bernard und der russian
ark plötzlichen buchenberg der kunde hat
[Musik]
und jedes jahr wenn das homophobie gott
dann nimmt das stück ist der weg in die
andere richtung
die kühlere jahreszeit verbringen sie im
haus ließ nach 2
einmal im monat später flüge ist denn
auch mit video wurde und den haag von
der welt nach zwei wochen sommerferien
diese noch nicht gelernt denn wenn sie
funktionieren und soll muss dann auch
gemacht
nach dass man auch nach den gründen
ja und dann ist ja schon da
[Musik]
es ist schick aus michel von lönneberga
und ihr kinder aus bullerbü führen dort
wieder manager vorstellen schwedische
pure hof
ich weiß dass ich wirklich wundert sich
neugierig
[Musik]
na ja gewaltig kennt das schon aber uns
natürlich noch nicht klar
und wieso selber dann auch mal bauer
werden wenn du groß bist ein
fußballspiel wirst du ja nicht du werde
nicht verstehe ich in der schweiz bin
auch schweizer du spielst in der
schweizer nationalmannschaft
ja natürlich weißt du wie sehen wir dann
froh weil wir können jeden guten fußball
spieler brauchen der maxi-single fußball
hof schnitt trainiert regelmäßig peter
junior vom fc aus dort die wissen dass
sport und führten nach dem mini das ist
fußball
am sonntagnachmittag ist am anfang sehr
von der denn wie schon heute noch
überwältigt vom ersten tag an dem
busfahrer
wir haben eine schneiden sich schnell
einig also ich finde ja doch sei es
überhaupt kein problem kann das gefühl
habe ich bin da nicht willkommen und uns
ist es leider im öffentlichen raum in
der schule lines jetzt eine übersetzerin
für arabisch für die ganze flüchtlingen
woche sinkt und die laufen ganz benommen
und übersetzer wenn irgend ein bisschen
klassisch und nein sie sind also sehr
offen wie stark sich mein mann war
schwer die tränen
ja das ist halt sehr steigt auch der
sommerferien in schwedisch kurse nicht
kannst du musst dich einem trainingskurs
das rheinische derby ist ein bisschen
fernsehen überhaupt und dynamik von
anbieter und dem bieter in der innen
kurs gegangen
schwedisch für einwanderung aber da ist
ja das ist hat sowie videos klasse
gefunden dass alle zu und kann sehr
schlechte lehrer
perfekt deutschland müsse schwedische
studie in göteburg damit können dieses
level und schweden also erstrecken
er ist streng und aus redet perfekt also
auch die wohn oder also ist später sagen
gehört kann unterschieden ob er jetzt
[Musik]
ich mach mich lachen
die krise sehr geduldig die geduldigste
man wie ich weiß
[Musik]
am genfer see wohnende peter feierabend
und seine frau janet sich um das
malaysia sind essbar
[Musik]
damit zeit die der schwitzt
hotelfachschule gemacht der zufall als
wähler besitzt syriens praktikum gemacht
hat oder psychisch
ich schlage ihnen beetz
[Musik]
sänger ich sie am anfang gesehen habe
sie war einfach so so natürlich und
herzlich und das hat mir von anfang an
gefallen deshalb wollte ich mehr wissen
von hier und jetzt mit der zeit weiß ich
dass hier einfach
sie ist so nett und sie macht eigentlich
alles was sie kann um uns glücklicher zu
machen und sie hat so viel aufgegeben
und sie
sie gibt so viel energie und das ist
einfach das ist ja nett und topedo in
schnellroda muslime aber auch dass janet
teil der schweiz blieben jetzt wenn
skandal um porno richtig hoch zitiert
ich freue mich dass wir jetzt endlich
diese hochzeit diese feier haben die wir
noch nicht hatten
weil auf dem papier sind wir ja schon
verheiratet und jetzt jetzt wird es
endlich auch wirklich und
also ich bin sehr gespannt wie das ganze
wird mit der teezeremonie und
diese braut spielen und ja das freut
mich sehr
diese braut spielen habe
[Musik]
das könnte schon recht vielversprechend
400 lütz in die glieder oder per live
oder siebter vor der brut viel vor in
cheltenham xc70 so komisch und vermietet
sie entsprechend vor allem jede mutter
ist nicht so glücklich das ja auch so
weit weg ist glaub ich weiß jetzt für
mich fest als praktikant und
student hier in der schweiz das war
nicht ganz einfach auch für sie und das
wenn sich das dann gesehen haben also
das hat ihnen dann auch weg haben oder
weil es hier ganz klar mehr komfort den
sie zu hause als hier in der schweiz zum
beispiel die besser viertes ass mein
mutter kaufen
die verbaute 04 muss ich immer alles
selber machen
460 gianetti der schweizer die häufig
schwierig zumal wenn sie sich beobachtet
[Musik]
ein großes festtage haben zb wie ich ihn
er sich als neues jahr immer nur
spaghetti und pizza barack obama
klimatisieren
nein das kann ich so sein ich muss
lernen und dann habe ich von meiner
mutter geworden
wie man am malaysischen gucken
am anfang bin ich hier es war von anfang
an gut aber jetzt ist es spitze
naja ok herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
sie hofft neue silo aber gleich eigene
ganz frühere das ist die große kunst für
ali bas unterschiedliche kulturen
kümmert lange braune brief ist das aber
so einfach wie beim hochwasser
[Musik]
wenn meister essen wir auflegt gabel und
löffel aber dein papa ist immer wenn ich
ein gabriel dafür geben ist er immer mit
dem angabe der 1 und es ist so das finde
ich komme ich einfach wenn ich den
löffel reis zu essen
[Musik]
schwere brände aller herrgottsfrühe
chance lässt es ist morgen um viel
ec kac achtung anja zimmermann nach der
handelsschule frauenfeld nur autos
längst zum sport oder fast gar aus purem
vordringen
sie hatten gute job keine autobranche
jetzt später stieg sie am morgen am 5
gummistiefel und gott 150
soja duo florian a
aber sagt petry also überhaupt dort sich
aus purer not vom michael kranich spitze
über und das überhaupt jemand mehr ist
eine farblose geschickt zum probieren
und kaufen ist und jeder war jetzt bis
jetzt mit südtiroler freiheit stellt
immer wieder als ein canal street
[Musik]
und warum er geschwiegen
die schweizer holten zu reden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
irgendwie total spannend also der hesse
schweizer wollte gängig und durch wo in
los angeles ist und irgendwie finden
diese namen also ich glaube aber schon
dass das zufall ist
[Musik]
dass sie bei dieser bis wir prominentes
istanbul
er hat sich als architekt namen gemacht
und sie ist bekannt die fitness
bloggerin der soziale medien unteren
pseudonym squad girl hat sich doris er
ins gefängnis bau einer von ihrer
vorlage offenbar hautcremes sie jeden
tag machte oder videoclips mit fitness
und ernährungstipps und stellt sie es
nichts videos schmieds übrigen selber
und da als die neue therme tiere
verneint und die meistens junge frauen
trainiert denn nicht einfach nur mit
sondern duschen sich wie jackie brown
dritte - darum dass mehr frühere lehrer
wie man es auch gesund wollten sondern
dass sie schön und sehr berührende
geschichte oder wo man sage niemals nie
betrogen
die frauen die macher von ihm gemacht
aber es geht immer nur um die andere und
natürlich für kritik oder extrem wichtig
aber wenn du aber zügig und ibm hat eine
münchen am schluss
[Musik]
die gut drei jahre sind die quere
motorisches bau wenn er von einer
geschäftsreise aus los angeles zurück
und freute sich fast wie am ersten tag
[Musik]
lang hat der türkisch schweizerische
übrigens im internet bequem hat immer
wieder mails facebook profilfoto doris
checkt
ich habe auf ihrem facebook profil hin
und wieder geschaut wie ihr
beziehungsstatus ist es ist nicht so
dass ich gesagt habe
aber plötzlich war ihr status wieder auf
single und da habe ich hier sofort eine
freundschaftsanfrage geschickt und sie
hat angenommen und wir begannen einen
monat lang jeden tag hin und her zu
telefonieren zu 45 stunden am tag
ich war da sehen sie hier in istanbul
nach einem monat musste ich hierher
fliegen und sie kann mich am flughafen
abholen
da haben wir uns erstmals gesehen
wir haben hallo gesagt begannen uns zu
küssen
für doris isnyer fragt sie ob sie sich
wieder auf die türkische marcelino
nachdem er speziell kritisch umgekehrt
hat den ferientag um fonds ihre frauen
größere rolle gespielt und zwar anders
als man denkt
ich wusste dass ich nicht mehr mit
seiner türkischen frau zusammen sein
wollte vielleicht nennt man das
schlechte erfahrungen jedenfalls hatte
ich irgendwie genug von der türkischen
mentalität
[Musik]
ich wollte ihr jemand mit mehr
selbstvertrauen fehlt jemand mehr
selbstvertrauen hat dann hat er auch
weniger grund zur eifersucht weniger das
gefühl kontrollieren zu müssen
ich wusste also was ich wollte und
märkte ihre art passt zu mir
[Musik]
zurück in südschweden tanja zimmermann
noch im stall auf dem weg zum morgen ist
heizung halben arbeitstag in der
schweizer stadt auf 87 60 geschafft
das muss man ja schon wählen
mal findet schwedischen senders und
große betriebe seien der hof schon
anfangs für darüber leitete als hat eine
große tradition gemacht haben
die zwei wochen der sommerferien wenn es
da wirklich hundertprozentig fall denn
den kann ich mir schon vorstellen
[Musik]
aber ich habe zwar ja gesagt also so
eine frage musst du auch mal noch viel
haben wir sie alle und ich club for a
dream und prof
das ist gut kommt die neue land immer
neue leber sowie wieder anja und kaum
jörg stufe auf a warum jeanette afonso
auf der pilger reagiert ich war
schockiert
in der türkei er doris gericht hinter
sich und freut sich über das neue glück
mit dem krieg und mehr reise des
unbekannte und wunderschöne georgi
bleibt schweizer brigid seiner mit dem
wachen hin und weg
[Musik]